it's time for roses and Rosie Dean so
now you have to open the wine thank you
so much for having me thank you for
being here you guys as you know while
Dean struggles to open this wine because
you're not a wine drink this is maybe
the second bottle of wine I've ever
opened in my entire life we are
recapping slash watching for the first
time because I didn't watch it re season
of The Bachelorette to get to know re
because to get to know because what
because who is re re is a racecar driver
what do you think about oh I did it
wait for the sound oh okay yeah
confirmed on tape that I can open a
bottle of wine are the standards are so
low right now there you go that's okay
okay so when we drink we have to like
hit a high note I don't know if you knew
it we every time we drink on this show
we go I'm coming for you what's your
go-to karaoke probably Wonderwall by
Oasis today he's gonna be the day I miss
his classics dark song what do you mean
how the dark
today is gonna be the day that they're
gonna bring me back to you by now you
should've so I'm happy lies what you
gotta do I don't believe anybody feels
the way I do about you now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm embarrassed for myself
Ahri's a racecar driver that one that's
basically all we know yeah I series the
first ever race car driver to go through
that's all right
I don't know don't know maybe I
obviously forget what your job title was
in the show recruiter what does that
mean I've recruited to start up Oh like
you would assign like get people jobs at
startup I mean if you want me they
talked about it if I worked at an agency
I guess I still technically work at an
agency that partners with early-stage
startups that are fresh out of a serious
Harry series be rather funding and are
looking to scale four maybe five to
twenty years wonderful and you probably
it feels like forever since I'm actually
senior there's two legitimate just like
like clips like the highlight reel of
the season appreciate the amount of time
go ahead and get comfortable because
we're in for the long haul first we have
Chris Harrison kind of talking to the
guys so let's play that clip well I know
he was created here's what's weird to me
he's explaining the whole show do they
still do this where they like sit down
and explain the whole show to you as a
group I honestly don't think so right
it's like we know ok clip number two I
just picked it because it's shirtless
guys at a pool muscles yeah that guy was
he not disaster he was not the bachelor
he has executive mental that's what it
was okay yes do you good memory did you
watch all seasons about sure I think
I've seen a couple clips
now how realistic is this it's at this
point is like 25 shirtless dudes at the
pool not seen characteristic of a pool
does it's just like what do you guys
talk about in those times in those
shirtless man bonding moments at the
pool like what came up I don't know a
lot of get to know yes yeah this is who
I am and where I'm from and this is why
I'm better than you and you're gonna
lose
did you and Peter become best friends
for life right away well we slept in the
same room I remember it was I think he
was like during the second rose ceremony
or something it was like when I was like
all right
this dudes like pretty cool yeah you're
like I think he like I like I like
looked up to him as an older brother
very early on I feel like you know okay
so we're gonna fill up a little bit in
honor of your high notes because look
Dean I love Rosie that's literally the
premise of the show give me my podcast
later so it's gonna be maybe my best one
yet your podcast and your podcast is
called so we can get to later it's okay
what's good I talk okay so here is the
moment we got two minutes of Ari it's
the cocktail party are you talking to
Emily so we are going to I'm gonna clean
up the desk and clean up our trash and
we're gonna try to focus on our yoga
Natalie you guys made me feel good
I know grateful see all you guys are
here so Emily looks beautiful tonight
I mean it feels like forever since I've
actually seen her since I haven't had a
date this week you didn't get a date
that's it wasn't any dates personally
like they come back with great stories
of how they connected what they did and
it's tough I have experience a little
bit with that you know I dated a girl
that has children and I love kids we
know children in the bath
yes that's good good to know I like how
you're analyzing this
very much I mean I am okay so let's talk
about the fact that you didn't get a
date at all that's for sure is that like
as a guy are you thinking about that so
much like I'm not owning the day it's
what I mean is it does it I'm trying to
think of the guys that didn't get dates
on the first week of ours and I don't
think any of them were the Kiva top six
so it's impressive that are you didn't
get a date the first weekend when all
the way to final two you made me nervous
I know I know you make me really nervous
so what is your one regret from the
Bachelorette if you have fun I don't
think I have any do you ever regret for
paradise sure I mean yeah can I give you
a my I would call it expert analysis
please I think that you were less
comfortable with yourself on the
Bachelorette was your first time on TV
you didn't think you were gonna make it
that far and so you were a little more
guarded a little more insecure like
sometimes a little bit more awkward and
then you kind of almost went the other
extreme on paradise and it was like ooh
copter and now when you go and winter
games you're gonna be perfect I mean
once again are we just assuming I'm
coming I support Ari as Bachelor I think
it's I think will be less interesting
for me personally than it would have
been with Peter but I still wish the
best for and the idea is in three weeks
from basically today I should be able to
get down on one knee and proposed her no
um Peter's great and I love him but he
kind of gets in his own head every once
in a while
were you surprised that you fell in love
with Rachel I went into the show very
open hey congrats to you by the way for
locking up the first post when in
Bachelorette interview with Peter Krause
Dean I want to thank you before
congratulating me on that I considered
that my Pulitzer moment and I know that
I'm gonna get it maybe even a Nobel
Peace Prize for journalism so Peters
going on winter games
our demon Peter gonna be on winter games
together yo I thought we already talked
about moving on to the next subject and
now here we are back at it back to your
other point I would only do the bachelor
Dave everything made sense I don't
personally I know it's not like a goal
of mine to be there okay but if I was
presented the opportunity and I wasn't
seeing anyone whatever it was and it
made sense for me the time I would
consider it
are you seeing someone now winter games
love to reunite with Peter in winter
games
I want to drink to you Dean that was a
smooth
are you single it's complicated sure
why are you suck at dating we know from
your buddies hey but I think I'm getting
better
yeah your podcast is called help
I suck at dating I would call that a
very clear brand message okay we need to
get to some other questions are you
still dating Christina it's complicated
okay
so that no it's calm I'm not like
interested in pursuing anyone but I
think that we're still at least having
an open line of conversation we're not
like dating but we're still thinking of
it why do you have such a hard time
I think I'm boring
I'm very interesting I think I'd rather
listen to someone else talk about
themselves than you talk about mine oh
I'm sorry thank you so much for being
here for roses and roses you rather
you're fabulous and we're gonna see you
on winter games so exciting thank you
for having me
hey guys my name is Dean Unger I have a
podcast called help I suck at dating
we're currently on episode 5 I have Eric
bigger in studio this week I can't wait
to interview him we're gonna talk about
astrology and what it means to be born
on certain days of the year and how that
pertains to your love life your love
languages etc etc I suck at dating but I
hope that you tune into my podcast and
help me suck a little bit less that was
a shameless blog with Dean woo
guys make sure to like you see on
Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube
follow Dean on social media and listen
to his amazing podcast and we will see
you every Tuesday morning with more
roses and Rosie
[Applause]
[Laughter]